well thousands of residents in the
Philippines have been ordered to
evacuate their homes after a volcano
began spewing ash into the sky
seismologists say the tale volcano could
erupt any day following a series of
earthquakes rumblings and magma flows
the Tal volcano lies just 65 kilometres
south of the Philippine capital Manila
which has closed its airport due to huge
plumes of ash belching from the volcano
the clouds have been generating volcanic
lightning to ash fall has made roads
travel dangerous in nearby towns school
classes have been canceled and residents
have been advised to stay indoors and
use masks for more on this were joined
by a DW correspondent Anna Santos in the
Philippine capital Manila hi Anna
what's the situation where you are now
the government has raised the alert
level to four out of a five point scale
and they're warning of a hazardous
eruption that may come within the next
hours for days and classes have been
suspended in areas in Metro Manila and
around the towns around the volcano also
all flights have been cancelled on
social media citizens who live here in
Manila which is about 40 miles away have
been posting photos of ash fall that has
collected on their cars their windows
and other homes it is really a very
tense situation right now and tell us
what's happening closer to the volcano
how dangerous is the situation there so
Jared the outlets are on a lake you know
it's surrounded by a body of water and
seismologist said warned of possible
volcanic tsunamis so these are surges
that may come about when you know a
volcano spews boulders or large
fragments into a body of water I spoke
to a resident from a nearby town around
town and she told me that right now
they're very scared they're very tense
and anxious the al volcano is making its
presence felt to them in every possible
way they see clouds of smoke coming from
the volcano
they feel its tremors through the
earthquakes and they continue to hear
rumblings from the volcano all
throughout the day and as I had spoken
to her just a few minutes ago
so these residents for these residents
it's not going to be easy to sleep
through the night and I could you talk
us through what the affiliate
authorities are doing how prepared are
they if the situation gets worse Sal
Vulcano the second most active volcano
in the Philippines and as early as March
last year the seismologist had already
been monitoring it for its activities
it's already showing rumblings you know
so and the Philippines are certainly not
stranger to natural disasters we're one
of the most natural disaster prone areas
in the world and now all of is that the
disaster preparedness and survival
skills are kicking in and the government
is on full alert over the next few hours
and days under santos in manila thank
you very much